seven herders fits in and count the
basket two games for Cleveland love with
eight on the shot clock
cross-court intercepted by herder Bob
ahead knock down
Geoffrey picks it up went three for
Spelman and he hits one in his
homecoming can local rolls with white
side if you don't it's gonna be tough
oh look at Kevin chances and assists
number 10 comes right here I mean Matt
Ryan would be thrilled to see that man
oh he that's a pinpoint tray polite to
dandy fastball from tray young gets
Kevin heard of the doughnuts to Spellman
murder with a deep three on food
Kevin Hornet has come out with a little
confidence in his shot beat plated what
time we're all together pray over the
rim harder followed see the nice deal
there by the Hawks and Trey is trying to
get a bucket he really is and he's not
[Music]
they're shooting in the bank
[Applause]
four-fifty getting it done his second
three and that was along with indeed Lee
driving Beverly giving fumbled away
picked up by Spellman licking out Kevin
hurt her
[Applause]
Charlotte three up six down on the road
partner with a steel while nickels were
told one another one of them nonchalant
passes Dorian French gets behind the
three-point line at nails his first shot
that's good to see that three ball
hasn't been there for in this season
course he's missed a considerable time
with the deity burger floats at him
further off the drive they're good
penetration their looks on the back down
around the basket yeah but with a good
overplay
yeah but hurt her right hip betrayed
yeah reversing score for Trey young
Thompson and hurt her again play boobs
in out of his hands he thought he got
fouled and so did his coach meanwhile
that is going to be John Collins was the
seventh Golden State Journal Kevin de
Collins a nice little hesitation nice
bounce pass behind the back of Looney
there is John Collins you know you're
the older guy seasoned veteran courtesy
727 something's turn it over Brown
a little bit too much he turns it over
no hump it makes up a little ground just
take two at a time and in her this case
three here is Irving on the LOB that
went behind vanes
base picks it off three on two Kevin
herder had to change his shot and laid
it in care for her to say I'm along with
you if you want to get out as one he
scores his 16th point then over the top
line will be a defending brother uses
the Alex plant strange moves in and
score run by Kevin hurt her nine points
but Noah Vonleh 71-64 Doozers pray you
know he's kind of a sporadic type of
player who doesn't bring energy all the
time
Kevin herder picks it off pays will they
play in at the other end
fun at all his sixth three-pointer of
the year driving and a deflection by
herder took it off the hand of Wiggins
Trey gets in ahead phase corner three
and the early autumn
[Music]
murder Wow
the Hawks are pouring it on now hear
from Derrick Rose a tip by Gibson for a
young fighter der get them left alone
hello and there's nobody near fooled but
he was speaking of Colin C on that first
game bats he said I was so glad he was
limited in his numbers because we had
nothing on nobody that could stop jump
shooter in the house first team foul on
Fox another block Alex Lynn he's got
that rep protected
to the whole series solid block fear of
the nice bounce pass
there is driven murder which is nice
dark at the rim buns swoops in to corral
the board up it comes to hurt her
Kevin to the basket and that's an ad one
to the polling place you saw to miss out
by then waited there Kevin heard pushing
the ball up the floor D'Angela
instead of playing deep Kevin against
grant it's the turnaround catheter
booster for Jeremy further cutting backs
and scores in a foul on Brooklyn again
another gallivant Hawks team down
bipolar they got Jimmy Butler on the
bench right now
15 for Kevin pick and roll with College
but nothing there the size of Billy on
front perfect gets a game is tied Kevin
Turner where you got moose collar
guarding heaven hurt he's not gonna he's
not gonna be able to guard him off the
dribble
muscala gesell a little bit too late
there
what a shot you think I was gonna give
you cardi be done up saying 73 64 Kevin
broken play Kevin quarter her to pick
that up to knock it down as an all-star
you really do he has been magnificent 14
points here the first half Kevin Trey
sips it behind the back Kevin herder
every three he's hit has been against
grant 32 8 Atlanta Kevin from deep
[Applause]
percentage Eco you can let down you he
go and sacrifice summers your game for
the betterment of team that's what it's
all about
Kevin harder
[Music]
drei the Aaron Berger picks off the back
pass intended for Marcus smart
four on one with Boris fitting around
can't stop playing good defense the
Hawks get their first fast break [ __ ]
into the knife kicks to the corner be
ELISA in block taken away by her that's
a very good defense there by the Hawks
Hawks coming three-on-two beverage it's
only in and funny healed to follow this
is goods lock here by Kevin hurt and he
was able to get the ball out make a nice
little bounce pass to Gremory up and in
starting to come and maybe make a year
ahead of schedule
yeah absolutely further steps in to pick
it off
for pepra all the way through covers of
the corner tray underneath by Kevin of
the quarters to of the shot clock
and Kevin hurt her nails a fridge top
shot selection sometimes he just taught
you about it with that turnover for Utah
that mary's episcopal dog
how much lays it in if you don't give
your teammate good pass such as inside
kevin hurt her with a nice bounce and
the Hawks laid it by one
glass and good time at Phoenix twice at
the other end
Kevin Herbert time out at Phoenix Kevin
Recovery's kids it underneath the
college he'll get Phoenix found good
no-call and then a wild scramble
Kevin harder with the look Ahead's
college was all alone a champion and
atlanta goes up 7 114 to 107 with one
minute and sixty seven to shoot
Tori Murden deep three from straight up
is born on the night Kevin Hart
[Music]
[Applause]
Kevin rises up storms up by the one
popular three-pointer for Kevin murder
bill didn't want to get another file so
he just flows out to close as he could
bound to cody zeller deflected and the
Hawks take it away Kevin hurt her gut
[Music]
this was the run out after the turnover
from 1588 Torian hits the corner three
Kevin gets the jam
Ingram's lost it great picks it up
leaves the break
trade leaves it for her turn off the
turnover I step back Trey young behind
the back to Kevin it's gonna get Houston
oh no it's it's a very vibrant color
that's for sure
poked away and here comes Atlanta on the
break Trey lobs it up to Spelman back
out murder got that one short gets it
back
[Applause]
well Kevin this goes up over and
marketing this throws that down with
authority look at his dunk here
beautiful 33% as a three-point shooter
brisk dog trotted up and under that was
woefully short that was Turner on the
leak out he'll slam it with one hand 19
to go in the opening frame and on the
run-out
Kevin murder throws it down for a dime
three Atlanta
[Applause]
his brother
into the paint old friend Wayne ways at
baseball at the time outlines Kevin
murder
he drops in his first report for a young
into the paint around Whiteside but he
recovers no shot Kevin will drive it
ballet style that's a nice move back
camera her Kevin the time again that
just not good defense six ball game in
favor the visitors from the Crescent
City well Kevin had a much smaller guy
going to hit the rim and banked it in
I mean first white gets the defense
behind in a nice hesitation move to set
it up off the glass in there off to take
on average thirty six threes again it is
your day young man hovering comes the
other way for the Hawks offense that
stole Trey nice feed here nice little
shuffle pants we had to check exact
rabbit
and ripped out of his hands by Torian
Prince three-on-two the other way to
look at that steel just ripped out of
there by Torian and again on the LOB tre
Jung has that little bunny hop in fact I
saw that coming all the way long way
down you're very young looks to move in
lobs it is that tre young he'll look lob
and murder knows how to finish he goes
up high tech sees it and throws it down
st. John Collins play the vibe in this
first half Devon hurt her back in turns
blokes and connects soft touch by Kevin
murder
murder God tipped out by harder
Kevin thanks drive time on Philadelphia
Kevin hurt her right down Peachtree with
the two-hander Hawks by two Kevin turns
the corner props at the job who got
behind everybody and a foul on seven and
a free throw for Dewayne Dedmon after
this blocking a foul by Simmons here
defended by Payton no for getting a hand
on the basketball Kevin will drive use
the hole isn't good Kevin hurt her that
was a beautiful drive there herder finds
Alex led for the jam
[Applause]
[Applause]
rebound Kevin he doesn't miss too many
open shots his passing ability his
shooting ability and he's and he's not
just a catch and shoot guy exactly he
could put it on the floor
yes not a good pass dare to devise
Harrison here comes the Hawks and Kevin
her with a knife look away and hope Bobo
I said well and John got that one in
battles to get the offensive rebound but
again he just out works using plants
Kevin brings another phrase they are
what we're about you know and that was
just drive to be like those these type
of guys to have someone date you can
emulate what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content